hello readers today we're going to talk
about how to use text features to find
information in a piece of nonfiction
writing like a textbook an encyclopedia
entry or a news article information in
these texts is organized with a specific
purpose in mind the author wants you to
be able to read the text features like a
map so you can find the information that
you need so the first text feature i
want to talk about today is the title
and that's just the name at the top of a
piece of writing and its purpose is to
tell you
really what you're about to read
let me give you an example we can see
this article here this text in yellow
this is the title and it says all about
pets what does that tell us about the
content of this writing it's going to be
all about pets now below it in green you
can see three examples of the next kind
of text feature that i want to talk
about
which are called headings
and we'll go back to that other screen
in a second don't worry and headings
organize information into sections
so we can see that there are three big
headings here we've got popular pets
unusual pets and taking care of your
pets these are the three headings that
all fall under the main topic of all
about pets smaller than a heading is a
subheading which organizes text into
even smaller sections so to go back to
the text again we can see that under the
main heading of popular pets there are
three subsections cats dogs and fish the
three most popular pets in the united
states another important text feature
you might see in a piece of writing is
bold text bold words and that's when a
word or phrase is printed in a thicker
darker letter and i'll show you exactly
what that looks like but the purpose of
it the reason that an author might
choose to include bold text in a piece
of writing is to point out important
terms to the reader specific words that
they want you to know and usually that's
in the interest of teaching you the
reader a new word if we scan this page
for bold text we can see i see three
examples do you see how the words are
darker and the letters themselves are
thicker that's what it means to be bold
that's what that's what it means for a
word to be bold so we've got rare
companions over here in this little
sidebar we've got the word endangered
and many times in pieces of writing that
use bold words like this there will be a
section at the end of the chapter called
a glossary which is really kind of a
holding pen for vocabulary words you
flip to the end you look at the glossary
and it lists all the bolded words and
their definitions
now i just referred to a sidebar which
is this little section here in this
orange yellow box now a sidebar is where
an editor or an author puts information
that doesn't really fit in the rest of
the text
so this is next to the unusual pets
heading and we can see that it begins
while having an unusual pet can be
perfectly fine it's connected to this
section but it's not essential to the
point of this paragraph sidebars are
where you put important information that
otherwise wouldn't fit into the piece
this teal box here
that says take a peek at what's inside
grooming tips three healthy treats five
training your pet eight this is a table
of contents so if this page all about
pets is the first page of a magazine
we've opened the cover now we're looking
at the first page then this little box
here is telling us what to expect in the
rest of the magazine what page numbers
we can find all of these other articles
on there's also a similar thing called
an index which is located in the back of
a book and that's just a list of all the
topics in the piece in alphabetical
order so if i want to flip to the back
of this piece of writing and and see if
i can find a place where it mentions
pugs i would go and start with a section
that begins with p look for a mention of
pug dogs and then i would go to the page
where pugs are listed then this final
heading on this page is called taking
care of your pet and what's interesting
about it is that it contains a bulleted
list
these little round dots we call bullets
sometimes putting things in a list like
this is the quickest most efficient way
to share information so this is a three
point list that all pets need some sort
of food and water place to sleep and
rest way to exercise or play
three different little points
and lists will either use bullets like
these little round things numbered lists
or sometimes lists that just use letters
of the alphabet for each point
so a food and water b a place to rest or
sleep let's see a way to exercise or
play now down here at the very bottom of
the page it says want to learn more
www.avma.org resources tools slash pet
owners slash pet care uh and when i move
my cursor over it
you can see there's a little like flag
the cursor changes to a pointy finger
and that means it's a hyperlink and
that's gonna take us to a website
and here we are on the website of the
american veterinary medical association
so this is a website operated by animal
doctors and you can see that this page
too is organized under the title of pet
care it's got a bunch of different
subheadings like responsible pet
ownership preventive care and keep them
healthy so to review the title tells us
what the article is going to be about
the heading divides up that article into
chunks the subheading divides it up into
even smaller chunks
sidebars contain text that wouldn't fit
elsewhere in the piece
bold type tells us what words the author
thinks are important for us to learn
tables of contents tell us what content
we can expect and finally hyperlinks
connect us to other places on the
internet where we can learn more things
you can learn anything
david out